when you're logging onto your email on a
public computer when you think that you
are going to be in next Bill Gates for a
William paywall or if you simply want to
check a different mail account at the
same time you may have seen yourself
turn to incognito mode it tells you that
all your information is private but is
it actually here's the truth about
incognito mode
[Music]
welcome to Horus hobbies when you
normally browse the Internet your web
browser stores information about the
website you visit for example the
product that you view on Amazon or the
videos that you watch on YouTube these
are called cookies if you guys want to
in-depth explanation on what cookies are
then make sure to check out my dedicated
video on it but anyways if you're
sharing computer with other people you
may not want sensitive logging
information saved on it like a bank
login information this is for incognito
comes in income does not store any
history cookies form data or anything
else from your online activity cookies
may be saved junior session but will be
deleted when you press the red X as a
result incognito works by not saving any
data from an online activity on your web
browser however it is very important to
remember that incognito mode only
prevents information from being saved
onto your web browser you can control
what your web browser saves and what it
does it but you cannot control what your
ISPs save or other servers your inter
provider will always be able to view
your history incognito mode only helps
you protect your privacy from other
people who also use their computer this
is why the homepage of incognito mode
itself informs you that your employers
may still be able to be your history so
it still isn't great again on Facebook
during work furthermore incognito mode
does not hide your IP address or change
it if you're thinking about pirating on
incognito mode then forget it because it
does not reduce the chance of you
getting caught furthermore
you shouldn't be party in the first
place anyways as a result if you're
looking to hide your IP address for any
reason the incognito mode will not
accomplish that for you if you really
want to become
the private on the Internet the best
solution available right now is to get a
VPN but something to keep in mind is if
you want to get a good secure VPN with a
great internet speeds then you are
definitely I'm going to have to pay
money for it on a monthly or annual
basis how be PN's work is that all the
data that flows from your computer to
the Internet is subject to a bank grade
encryption level this ensures that there
is no logging of your download history
web browsing history or even your IP
address if you're looking to go down
this path then one of the best options
available right now is tor
also if you guys are interested in how
VPNs work and if it is worth it for you
to make sure to come and dedicate a
video on it right there going back to
incognito mode in the end many people
are under a false impression then
kognito mode is a safer way to surf the
Internet it is certainly a great way to
ensure that other people using your
computer don't see your data but it does
not stop your operating system your
router your ISP or web sites from
tracking your online activity as a
result incognito mode definitely has its
purpose and can be quite useful in
various scenarios but just make sure to
keep in mind what incognito mode can and
cannot do
but that's all I have for you guys this
time do you guys use incognito mode
often and if so for what purpose also if
you guys find video helpful then make
sure got to like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but till then
I'm hurry now see you guys on the next
one
[Music]